you're a very successful businesswoman
now so your path was very unusual so how
did this all start
well you know I grew up in a world where
women are less than right I think the
easiest way to explain it is that from
the time a child is old enough to speak
until the day that they die if you are a
male if you're a boy as you become a man
your entire life you say when you wake
up in the morning you say thank you God
for giving me life and then you say
thank you God for not making me a woman
what thank you God for not making me a
woman like literally they say every day
from the day they're old enough to speak
you see your son saying it you watch
your husbands how that must impact you
as a woman in that Community wow that's
tough
um and wow and you said your daughter
changed your life right my daughter
Miriam is the reason I'm alive I mean
that's just the fact you said your
daughter changed your life as well
absolutely yeah she was born I had to
change me yeah to fit my daughter
so well speaking back of your daughter
was there one moment that kind of stuck
out and I want her to be like y'all
she's watching y'all
she's watching you
and he's watching God I know and we also
want you to be whoever you are deep in
there that's that's yeah that's to be
whoever you want to be so my daughter's
name yeah you lead the the beginning of
my story and the person who helped me
leave because it was an eight-year
trajectory and it started when Miriam
was five years old I have a daughter
named Miriam
she was asking well I would like to play
ball I wanted I want to play basketball
I wanted to do this I want to learn how
to sing and I want to play the guitar
and she was constantly said no you can't
dance in public because a man might see
you and have bad thoughts you can't sing
in public because a man might see you
and have bad thoughts and my little
five-year-old turned to my husband and
she would say but why isn't that his
responsibility my five-year-old out of
the mouth and then for the first time
she gave me permission because my entire
life I thought I was bad that it wasn't
okay for me but you couldn't convince me
that my five-year-old was bad and she
was saying this doesn't make sense why
can't men control themselves and by the
way thank you why can't men use all
themselves excuse me yeah and by the way
they can and they yeah yes they can they
can and so that was when I started
educating myself it took me eight years
before I walked out the door if I had
stayed she would have been married off
at 18 or 19 like everyone else yeah she
certainly wouldn't be in college she
certainly wouldn't be a tech genius well
she changed your life and you changed
her that's it yeah I mean we literally
saved each other yeah you know wow
okay so what's your favorite thing to do
um and now that you know now that you
would have been forbidden to do
something before like what's your
favorite thing to do dance oh I do love
to dance I love dancing yeah I love
dancing yes and so to be able to
actually move to just let go and dance
is something I really love I love that
[Music]